buongiorno oggi vi parlerò della lis
quanti di voi sanno che cos'è la lis
alzate le mani
ok qualcuno c'è allora vediamo subito un
filmato che ci dà la misura della
conoscenza che abbiamo della lis
[Musica]
se le dico liszt lei cosa mi dice
lisbona è una cosa da una psicologica
niente lo so
la lis no cos'è la lis cosa cioè i s e
basta non lo so sai cos'è la lista no e
se le dico lingua dei segni le veramente
qualcosa
esattamente si la lingua dei segni per i
sordomuti sì
qualche segno strano come mani ste cose
qua le persone cioè corso allora la lis
è la lingua dei segni italiana la lingua
della comunità sorda segnante in italia
il mio incontro con la lista è stato
casuale durante gli anni dell'università
che ho trascorso a urbino la facoltà di
lingue e letterature straniere
il ragazzo che frequentava allora
giacomo mi parlò della lingua dei segni
italiana e mi incuriosì tanto pensai che
la leaf se fosse una lingua molto
diversa noi in un certo senso dalle
lingue che studiavo in università come
il tedesco oppure l'inglese perché è una
lingua che si esprime anche attraverso
il corpo attraverso le espressioni del
viso
quindi decisi di seguire il mio primo
corso di liszt
proprio qui all'inter nazionale sordi di
ancona anni più tardi l'incontro con la
professoressa di linguistica generale
dell'università di urbino
caterina donati in qualche modo decise
la mia professione futura caterina
donati mi incoraggia a proseguire lo
studio sulla liszt in maniera più
scientifica più linguistica più rigorosa
e grazie ad un'altra linguista un'altra
donna la professoressa anna cardinaletti
dell'università ca foscari di venezia
oggi sono ricercatrice e docente di
lingua dei segni italiana all'università
ca foscari di venezia che l'unica
università in italia in cui ci si può
laureare in lingua dei segni italiana
i nostri studenti scelgono la lis
insieme a una delle 17 lingue offerte
dal dipartimento di studi linguistici e
culturali comparati nel 2016 un gruppo
di linguisti di
i ricercatori internazionali di cui
faccio parte ha ottenuto un importante
finanziamento europeo un horizon 20 20
per studiare e promuovere e diffondere
la lingua e la cultura delle comunità
sorde segnanti il progetto si chiama
sign
ab sono sette i paesi che partecipano a
questo progetto la spagna la francia la
germania i paesi bassi la turchia
israele è per l'italia l'università ca
foscari di venezia e l'università di
milano bicocca insieme anche alla
collaborazione dell'istituto statale
sordi di roma
il progetto quadriennale quindi
terminerà nel 2020 gli obiettivi di
questo progetto sono quattro
il primo obiettivo è quello di scrivere
la grammatica di sei lingue dei segni
per la lis
si tratta della prima grammatica di
riferimento
vi chiederete come si fa a scrivere la
grammatica di una lingua che non ha una
forma scritta è un si tratta di
grammatiche digitali quindi metteranno
insieme più contenuti il testo scritto
ci sarà una versione italiana è anche
una in inglese perché possa essere
accessibile anche all'estero
accanto al testo che spiega le
costruzioni e
linguistiche grammaticali della lingua
ci saranno delle degli esempi concreti
con delle grosse che trascrivono i segni
e abbinato a queste grosse questi esempi
i video sottotitolati in lingua dei
segni italiana perché si possa vedere
realmente come funziona la lingua e poi
delle immagini tante immagini che
ritraggono i segni questo per rispettare
la natura visiva della lingua dei segni
italiana
secondo obiettivo sarà quello di
realizzare un atlante linguistico che
contenga le informazioni sulle
caratteristiche principali delle lingue
dei segni del mondo esiste già un
atlante linguistico per le lingue vocali
ma non ancora per le lingue dei segni
terzo obiettivo è quello di sviluppare
dei test che siano utili per
diagnosticare i disturbi del linguaggio
in lingua dei segni
per quanto riguarda la lis esistono
pochi test che diagnosticano ad esempio
la dislessia oppure disturbi
dell'apprendimento nei bambini sordi ma
non l'abbiamo test diagnostici per gli
adulti questo significa che se una
persona sorda adulta a una un danno
cerebrale dovuto a un ictus
oppure a una malattia degenerativa un
incidente non possiamo valutare se è
subentrato un disturbo del linguaggio
non abbiamo i test per farlo e non
possiamo neanche riabilitarlo al
linguaggio il quarto obiettivo è quello
di creare un archivio digitale che
contenga e che renda tutti questi
materiali saranno accessibili online
una volta terminato il progetto quindi
accessibile a tutti il dicevo il quarto
obiettivo è creare un archivio digitale
delle interviste che abbiamo
raccolto dei sordi anziani e questo per
due obiettivi principali uno è quello di
conservare la loro eredità linguistica
la lingua dei segni non ha una forma
scritta
quindi la varietà del segnato delle
persone anziane sorde e a rischio di
estinzione se non viene il video
registrato e dall'altra parte invece
quello di conservare l'eredità culturale
della comunità sorda anziana in quanto
testimoni di eventi storici europei
cruciali come la seconda guerra mondiale
come i grandi cambiamenti sociali del
novecento che sono filtrati attraverso
gli occhi di una comunità
inascoltata e poi la comunità sorda una
storia molto travagliata che forse non
molti conoscono nel 1880 il congresso di
milano voto
naturalmente erano gli udenti quelli che
presero la decisione voto nei confronti
della educazione che bisognava impartire
ai sordi votò contro l'uso della lingua
dei segni e in favore dello rallismo che
prescriveva all'esclusiva uso della
lingua vocale
allora vediamo un piccolo estratto dei
filmati delle interviste che abbiamo
raccolto
quindi il progetto nasce dall'esigenza
di sostenere e di promuovere la lingua e
la cultura delle comunità sorde che sono
comunità da sempre emarginate e in
qualche modo invisibili di loro sappiamo
molto poco quello che sappiamo spesso è
inesatto ad esempio continuiamo a
chiamarli sordomuti una parola che
implica che siano muti mentre non lo
sono affatto il loro apparato vocale
integro come il nostro li chiamiamo non
udenti negando una condizione che
pensiamo sia la normalità come se loro
chiamassero noi in un sordi in realtà è
il termine giusto è sordi oppure ci
riferiamo alla loro lingua come al
linguaggio a un linguaggio questo
termine indica un sistema di
comunicazione che però non possiede le
caratteristiche linguistiche delle
lingue naturali infatti parliamo del
linguaggio del corpo del linguaggio del
computer ma non parleremo mai del
linguaggio italiano no diciamo la lingua
italiana
e così dovremmo dire la lingua dei segni
oppure diciamo che si esprimono in gesti
invece si esprimono insegni la
differenza è che mentre i segni sono
delle entità linguistiche complesse che
possono essere scomposte al loro intorno
al loro interno in unità minime così
come le parole i gesti no i gesti fanno
parte del linguaggio mimico non sono
entità linguistica ecco questa ignoranza
questa disattenzione che abbiamo nei
confronti della comunità sorda
purtroppo ha delle conseguenze gravi nel
2006 la convenzione l'assemblea generale
dell'onu
con la convenzione sui diritti delle
persone con disabilità ha intimato gli
stati membri a riconoscere a sostenere e
diffondere la lingua dei segni del
territorio nazionale tutti gli stati
membri hanno recepito questa convenzione
questa direttiva tranne l'italia
l'italia e dopo dodici anni dalla
convenzione
l'unico paese europeo a non aver ancora
riconosciuto la lingua dei segni
italiana
e questo mancato riconoscimento
giuridico ha delle conseguenze sulla
violazione dei diritti primari dell'uomo
di quali diritti parliamo diritto
all'istruzione un bambino sordo oggi in
italia non riceve la stessa istruzione
di un bambino udente
parliamo del diritto alle pari
opportunità e le pare accessibilità in
tutte le sfere della vita pubblica in
ospedale
io ho personalmente sono stata testimone
di una donna sorda e stata portata una
sera in emergenza in pronto soccorso
aveva un infarto e non c'era un
interprete non c'era nessuno che potesse
mediare tra lei e il medico ed era
questione di vita o di morte perché il
medico doveva capire cosa era successo
quali erano i sintomi ma nessuno era in
grado di di fare da ponte oppure il
diritto alla partecipazione sociale se
una persona sorda vuole partecipare a un
convegno non può farlo perché non c'è
l'interprete oppure a un normale
sviluppo linguistico cognitivo e sociale
sappiamo dagli studi linguistici che sia
un bambino non viene esposto entro una
finestra temporale limitata che va dagli
zero a circa 12 anni di vita a un input
linguistico sufficientemente ricco non
potrà mai più sviluppare una lingua ecco
e per i sordi l'unica lingua naturale
che può garantire un pieno sviluppo
linguistico e cognitivo che può
garantire un pieno un ricco input
linguistico sono le lingue dei segni e
la comunità sorda un caso particolare di
minoranza linguistica perché il 95 per
cento di bambini sordi nasce da genitori
udenti
vuol dire che si verifica la situazione
paradossale che tra genitori figli non
c'è una lingua in comune e quindi la
normale acquisizione linguistica che
avviene di da genitori il figlio non può
avvenire e di qui il rischio che il
bambino
non sordo non abbia un normale sviluppo
linguistico e cognitivo
quindi occorre che sia l'ambiente
circostante alla famiglia la scuola ad
esempio a fornire limpo di linguistico
di cui ha bisogno
ecco nonostante quello tutte le false
credenze le informazioni sbagliate che
abbiamo la lingua dei segni italiana è
una lingua complessa naturale così come
lo è l'italiano indipendente
dell'italiano possiede una addirittura
una fonologia una morfologia e una
sintassi molto ricche si fa poesia si fa
teatro si fa cinema in lingua dei segni
italiana è sempre di più questa è una
cosa molto importante negli ultimi
decenni linguisti educatori stanno
utilizzando la lingua dei segni italiana
con bambini udenti perché è diventato
l'unico strumento di comunicazione per
bambini che hanno disabilità della
comunicazione per i quali utilizzare la
lingua vocale non è possibile nei casi
di autismo
nei casi di di sprazzi e verbali nei
casi di molte sindromi tra cui la
sindrome di down la sindrome di landau
klaffner e anche in casi di disturbi
dell'apprendimento
quindi il progetto avrà come come
prodotto la prima grammatica di
riferimento per la lis test diagnostici
che ci consentono di diagnosticare i
disturbi del linguaggio ma anche
contribuirà alla formazione dei bambini
e degli adulti sordi degli interpreti di
tutte le persone che si occupano che
hanno un ruolo in campo educativo e poi
ci auguriamo veramente che sia un
contributo per il riconoscimento della
lingua dei segni italiana e dei diritti
della comunità sorda
questo è il sito del nostro progetto
italiano e abbiamo anche una pagina
facebook se volete visitarla grazie
[Applauso]